Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Apparently, Marvel has just fired Jonathan Majors
Within an hour of me posting this video.
I waited a little while to see we get some more news
or some follow ups from some of the trade magazines
that were reporting on this.
But it does look like he is out at Marvel as Kang
the Conqueror or variants of Kang just in general.
I know there's a ton of questions about what happens
now, like what is going on behind the scenes,
what went down. So we'll try to break everything down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
It is just the beginning.
Like this is a very developing situation.
he's been in the middle
of a court case right now
against the person that accused him of abuse.
He was just found guilty by the court.
And now, obviously, he's going to be filing appeals.
But even if he is able to appeal
and clear his name over the next couple of years,
it doesn't really matter for his future.
Marvel like Disney.
Marvel essentially fired him.
And that's the end of the story for them.
my theory right now is that Marvel probably decided
to fire him a long time ago, like much earlier
this year, and just did him a solid by waiting
to announce it until his verdict was announced.
like even if he'd been found not guilty,
they probably still would have fired him.
the announcement about him being fired came
like literally minutes after the guilty
verdict was announced.
So it just lets you know that Disney
Marvel had their fingers on the firing trigger,
like they probably already made their decision
a long time ago.
Like they'd already had all those meetings
behind the scenes
and they were just waiting to hear the verdict
to actually announce that they'd fired him.
so it wasn't like
there was a chance that he could stay on.
If he was found innocent,
they still probably would have moved past him
and found a way to recast the actor
or just completely move past the Kang concept
in general and use a completely different villain
for Avengers five.
lot of people have been pointing
to the example of Terrence Howard
being recast from the first Iron Man movie
as Rhodey with Don Cheadle's character.
When we got to Iron Man two
I know there's a bunch of big questions like,
what is Marvel actually going to do?
Are they just going to recast the character
Are they going to decide to not do Kang Dynasty
and just do Avengers five and Secret Wars
like Skip straight to Secret Wars.
it seems like most of the people
that are reporting on him being fired
by Marvel are saying that they're just going to recast
and there'll be a different villain
in the Council of Kang's
The different Kang variants during Avengers five.
But the Council of Kangs
will still be the main villain of Avengers five
if they got to recast him,
there are a number of viable options.
Like you could bring in Denzel Washington
is just another version of Kang the Conqueror.
You could literally pick anybody that you want there,
discredit the whole concept of variants
during Loki season one and Loki season two,
and we'll see more variance during Deadpool three.
marvel also recently hired Michael Waldron
to rewrite Avengers five.
He's a former Rick and Morty writer who they had right.
Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness in Avengers
six Secret Wars.
They had previously hired Jeff Loveless
to write Avengers five Kang Dynasty.
He's another Rick and Morty writer like Marvel's
been stealing a bunch of Rick and Morty writers.
Jeff Loveless also wrote Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania.
He wrote that Council of Kang's
Post-Credits scene setting up Avengers five.
So it is possible
that Marvel had been spending the last
few months planning on Jonathan Majors being fired in.
They hired Michael Waldron onto Avengers
five in order to cause correct
for the recasting it remember that's not a recent thing
like that happened a while ago.
They hired him on a while ago.
so it does sound like they plan to course correct
from Jonathan Majors a long time ago.
what are they going to do now?
Like previously the reports had been that
they would do Avengers five is Kang Dynasty.
The new version of the Avengers
would form in the main 616 universe.
They would fight the Council of Kangs, they would lose.
But then another Kang variant would surface,
kill the Council of Kangs himself.
Like who can kill the Council of Kangs?
But another Kang?
then that new version of Kang
would become the main villain, like a beyond
or variant of Kang during the secret wars
they would do for Avengers six.
But then.
After all the problems with Jonathan Majors
started happening earlier this year
and there was a weak response to Kang the Conqueror
just in general during Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania, I would say
Jonathan Majors was actually pretty good in that movie.
The material that he was given was not that great,
though.
had they given him a better ending,
like a better script?
Just in general, the reception to his character
probably would have been way better
because he was great during Loki, Season one is the
he remains
variant of Kang
and he was great during Loki season two.
So I don't think it was the Kang character
that people had problems with.
I think it was just the Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania movie just in general.
personally.
What I think Marvel should do is just do Secret
Wars is a two part movie.
So instead of doing Avengers five, is Kang Dynasty,
they just do it as Secret
Wars Part one
and then the original Avengers six esque Wars Part two.
Even if they want to change the title for Part two,
they literally did that same thing for Avengers
Infinity War in Avengers Endgame.
Originally, if you remember the title card for that
like years and years ago.
Originally it was just called Avengers
Infinity War Part one in part two.
It's literally going to be the same situation
for Avengers five and Avengers six.
It'll just be Secret Wars broken into two big stories.
that's probably the real reason
why they had the original writer for Secret Wars
do Avengers five as well,
because they just wanted to expand the Secret War story
and make it a two part movie.
but after all those problems started happening earlier
this year, Jonathan
Majors was accused
in that whole court process, started with him.
It sounds like Marvel pivoted for Avengers six
and wanted to move past
the whole Kang character
like they'd still plan on doing Avengers five.
Is Kang Dynasty, but they wanted to do Secret Wars
with a completely different villain.
That's where all the Doctor Doom
or got Emperor of Doom, a rumor started.
it sounds like regardless of what they do
for Avengers five, unless they just straight
get to Secret Wars, they will use a completely
different villain than they planned before.
As the main villain of Avengers six.
I already did a much bigger video about them
introducing a version of Doctor Doom
in the next couple of years.
They still have till 2027
till they plan to release Avengers
six secret wars unless they change things
and make secret wars Avengers five.
So these are several years
to figure out what they want to do with that movie.
here's the thing, though.
This is why Marvel is getting down to the wire.
Why the play announce the recasting pretty soon,
or whatever they wind up doing with Avengers five,
because if they want to release that movie by May 2026,
they have to start rolling cameras
by the end of next year, which isn't that long.
It's not as long as it seems, In fact,
if you don't remember the behind the scenes,
the making of Avengers Infinity War,
in Avengers Endgame, some of the visual effects
on these big Avengers
movies take up to four years to finish.
No joke.
They actually had to start working
on the visual effects for the final battle
in Avengers Endgame four years
before they released the movie back in 2015.
that means right
now, Marvel probably knows what the final battles
are going to look like during Avengers
five and Avengers six, and they already have concept
artists and visual effects artists
starting to work on those battles in the characters in
them are the only things that are going to change,
like they might decide they want to use
slightly different characters in those
are the only things that they'll wind up swapping.
But like the giant overarching
big battles won't change that much.
So that's why Marvel was getting down to the wire,
trying to figure out what they were going to do
about Jonathan Majors either recasting
or going with a completely different villain
that had nothing to do with the concept of Kang.
and here's the thing about that.
To a lot of you
probably realize they use the ending for Loki.
Season two Episode six in that finale
to basically give themselves a couple different outs
if they decided to pivot completely on the idea of Kang
or just simply recast
during the Loki ending, they establish God,
Loki's powers and control over the multiverse.
He had the ability to manipulate timelines
like he argue with Mobius.
How do you know what to change, what to control,
what to mess with?
meaning that he did have the ability to mess
with the different timelines as much as he wanted.
So Marvel essentially was giving themselves
an option to have Loki be the one to deal
with all the Kang variants.
And they also set things up inside the TVA to explain
that their new mission was dedicated to finding
and capturing all the other Kang variants themselves to
so be just as easy option too
for Marvel to say
that the TVA took care of all the Kangs if they truly
want to swerve on Avengers five being Kang Dynasty
and just want to go to a completely different villain.
Let me know in the comments
if they do want to just get rid
of the whole concept of Kang
All different Kang variants.
The Council of Kangs by the end of Avengers five.
Who do you want to be
that main villain of Avengers six?
They could either do a straight up
version of the Beyond Earth
that is like an actual beyond or
and not just another Kang variant.
Or they could do God Emperor Doom because he was
the main villain of the more recent Secret Wars.
right now it seems like the MCU movie version
of Secret Wars they're going to do is going to be based
on both the 1980s version and the more modern version
of Secret Wars, which are completely separate plots.
During the original 1980s Secret wars,
it was a beyond a character who brought a bunch
of the different Marvel characters to battle world
to fight each other for his own entertainment.
Basically, if you never watched Spider-Man the animated
series back in the nineties, it's a great series.
I would recommend checking it out.
They actually did a version of that secret
war storyline during that series.
the newer version of Secret Wars
was a much bigger story
and involved a bunch of the different Marvel
characters, both heroes and villains,
fighting a bunch of the beyond race of characters
Until Doctor Doom
wound up being the one to defeat them,
taking their power to make himself God Emperor of Doom.
And as the multiverse was collapsing on itself,
he took all the remnants of the surviving universes
and combined them into a single one battle world
where all the survivors lived
whatever they wind up doing for the movie
version of Secret Wars.
It won't be exactly like the comics,
but you'll see a lot of Easter eggs
and references to those both eighties
in the more modern version of Secret Wars.
like I said,
they still have a couple of years to introduce
the Doctor Doom character if they do want to use God.
Emperor Doom is the main villain of Secret Wars,
but they could just as easily
use a completely different villain
either way, we're starting to get really close
to Avengers five coming out, so they need to start
teasing it in some of their post-credits scenes
the next couple of years.
Probably Deadpool three will be like
the first big plays that they do that I've already done
a bunch of videos about all the footage
that we've gotten from Deadpool three.
It all looks amazing.
It is going to be the craziest movie ever.
So as much as a downer is all this Jonathan
Majors stuff is at least there is Deadpool
three to look forward to.
everyone posts all your reactions in the comments below
and if they do just straight up recast
Jonathan Majors with another actor to play different
Kang Variance or a bunch of different actors
to play different Kang Variance, let me know
in the comments who you want that new person to be.
What's happening next?
Is it the
What if Season two episodes are starting this week
I'll be doing episode videos for that,
so make sure to enable trailers for my channel
so you don't miss any of those.
I do not expect to see Kang during any of those,
but I don't think that has anything to do
with what happened with Jonathan Majors.
I think they just didn't use a lot of Kang in it
just to begin with because it sounds like they started
working on
what if season two before Loki Season one came out.
So they haven't even really decided what they were
going to do with the Kang character at that time.
any of the big new X-Men, Fantastic Four stuff,
even Deadpool stuff showing up in animation,
the Marvel animated stuff probably wouldn't be too
like what if season 3 or like after X-Men 97
What they'll probably do is just remove
all mention of Kang in the next couple of years
worth of movies that aren't absolutely essential.
Like you just will not hear characters
talking about Kang or the Council of Kangs at all.
It really does seem like Marvel is hanging
a lot of its hats on Deadpool three right now.
Like Kevin, Foggy was just spotted at Wrexham
at a game with Ryan Reynolds and all of his people.
but there is a lot of really big stuff
to look forward to.
Like X-Men 97 episodes
I've already done a teaser video for that,
so I'll link it below in the description
So do not be surprised
if, given all the drama that's happened recently,
Marvel starts to pivot heavily towards X-Men
in Fantastic Four characters.
everyone click here to learn what's going on
with Deadpool 3 for all those teasers,
all the footage that came out, and then click
here for my new what If season two trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!